l'emballage de plusieurs produits
amiantés très abîmée se dégradent ici au
quartier cordiaux gros monde à l'entrée
du monde congo par temps de pluie
les résidents avance qu'ils sont
incommodés par des émanations de gaz à
la limite toxiques
malgré son opposition cette mère de
famille a assisté au ballet de camions
dans le secteur il y a près une dizaine
d'années les choses j'étais chez moi et
j'ai aperçu une grosse voiture qui fait
marche arrière et puis je suis venu voir
le gall il a avait il appelle un astre
dans son usage et puis la voiture il n'y
avait pas de numéro allez je lui ai dit
monsieur c'est ici n'est pas une
déchetterie n'avez pas le droit de
mettre les déchets alors ses papiers
c'est pour lui et il m'a répondu ça
prend de cherves dériverait aussi elle
fait des par le dépôt de toute espèce de
déchets dans un secteur durant l'année
non respect aussi des gens qui habitent
quoi donc là entre les vieilles voitures
qui sont entreposés dans ce quartier à
l'insu de tout le monde on vous trouvez
une voiture un jour comme ça sera un
matin pour trouver une voiture
entreposés
aujourd'hui c'était l'époque des dépôts
sauvages et les prouver qu'une fois
dommage et l'amiante constitue un vrai
danger pour la santé un centième de
micros si aussi ou encore la beauté
devient irrespirable
les fibres d'amiante sont persistantes
les risques de cancer et d'autres
maladies sont bien réels
c'est pas un petit pollution qui la ctq
en décharge et iut ni 10 feuilles
fribourg simon disponible avec les
amiantés à la rigueur au pdi bon look
afin d'opposer dieu pour activer la adam
quantité à qui l'a obligé prend sa fin
les services de cloud et al la rs tous
les services compétents semblait caillou
et puis dit population 10 - à travers
population qui sert qu'à mettre en place
pour tirer ça là
constitué un collectif les résidents du
quartier cordiant souhaite maintenant
que ce produit pour lyon soit rapidement
dégager de la zone